الأصدقاء ،
هذه المياه الهادئة هي موطن لسر
لا تريد روسيا أن تعرفه ،
يقول الخبراء إن إيران ترسل بهدوء
أسلحة على متن سفن مثل هذه عبر
بحر قزوين لتجديد الأسلحة من
حرب موسكو على أوكرانيا التي
تخفي الحركة في البحر تعتبر
شائنة وربما  انتهاكًا
للقانون الدولي
ولكن في بحر قزوين ، هناك
عدد متزايد من الفجوات في بيانات تتبع السفن
المعروفة باسم AIS مع زيادة بنسبة تزيد عن 50 في المائة
في السفن التي تخفي تحركاتها
بين أغسطس وسبتمبر من عام 2022
وفقًا لبيانات الاتجار البحري
لمعظم السفن  أظلمت
ناقلات العلم الإيراني أو الروسي ،
فالتوقيت مشكوك فيه أيضًا ، حيث
بدأت هذه الممارسة في الصيف الماضي تمامًا كما
كشف مسؤولو البيت الأبيض أن
روسيا قد اشترت مئات الطائرات بدون طيار
من إيران ،
فلماذا تريد هذه السفن إخفاء
تحركاتها محلل الأمن البحري
مارتن كيلي يقول  من
المحتمل أنه بسبب ما تحمله هذه السفن ،
هناك علاقة بين
روسيا التي تطلب طائرات بدون طيار من
مكالمات ميناء إيران المظلم في بحر قزوين
وزيادة الظلام كنشاط وهذا
مؤشر موسيقى رئيسي لهذه
الجوانب الثلاثة مجتمعة أن شيئًا ما كان
يحدث  حول تصدير
الطائرات الإيرانية بدون طيار إلى روسيا ، تُظهر خريطة الحرارة هذه من
قائمة Lloyd أين تتركز معظم هذه
الفجوات في AIS في الغالب بالقرب من
ميناء mirabad الإيراني وميناء Astra
Khan الروسي حيث يبدو أن السفن تقوم
بإيقاف تشغيل بياناتها عند الاقتراب
والظلام.  لفترات طويلة من الوقت
الآن باستخدام بيانات مثل هذه ،
تمكنت CNN من تحديد ثماني
سفن أبدت
سلوكًا مشبوهًا في بحر قزوين ، هذه إحدى
هذه السفن وهي عبارة عن Tinker علم روسي
شوهد في أوائل يناير تاركة
ميناء أمير أباد الإيراني مما يجعلها  في الطريق
عبر بحر قزوين إلى
ميناء أسترا خان في روسيا ، لا يمكننا الآن
التحقق بشكل مستقل مما كانت تحمله هذه الناقلة ، لكن
الخبراء يخبروننا أن الشحنة كانت على الأرجح
مرتبطة بتجارة الأسلحة ،
وهناك دلائل على أن نهران قد يكون يرسل
أسلحة عبر البريد الجوي للولايات المتحدة
وأوكرانيا.  اتهمت طهران بإرسال إمدادات
إلى روسيا على متن طائرة قامت
سي إن إن بتحليل بيانات التعقب لأربع
طائرات شحن إيرانية وضعت علامة عليها من قبل
وزارة التجارة الأمريكية لاحتمال
الاهتمام بشحنات الطائرات بدون طيار بشكل
جماعي ، قامت الطائرة بما لا يقل عن
85 رحلة إلى مطارات موسكو بين مايو
2022 ومارس 2023.
[موسيقى  ]
اعترفت إيران بأنها باعت
عددًا صغيرًا من الطائرات بدون طيار إلى روسيا ، لكنها تقول إن
البيع كان قبل بضعة أشهر من
الحرب في أوكرانيا.  من المحتمل أن تكون
سفن الشحن كبيرة الحجم التي يمكن أن تحمل ممر بحر قزوين
هي القناة الرئيسية
ويقول الخبراء إنها الحدود الجديدة
لتجارة الأسلحة بين موسكو وطهران
بعيدًا عن التدخل الغربي ،
فهي توفر طريقًا سهلًا
لخبيرة التهرب من العقوبات أنيسة التبريزي تقول
أعتقد أن التصور  في موسكو هو أن
إيران يمكنها أن تعلم موسكو الكثير حول كيفية
الذهاب وكيف لا يزال لديها
اقتصاد مهم حتى عندما
تُفرض العقوبات ولا يوجد الكثير مما
يمكن للولايات المتحدة وحلفائها القيام به لإيقافها
ويمكن أن يكون هناك المزيد في الطريق
حذر مسؤولو المخابرات في تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) من أن إيران تخطط
لإرسال ذخيرة صواريخ باليستية
وطائرات بدون طيار أكثر تطوراً إلى موسكو ، وهو
ممر مزدحم يحتمل أن
يوفر أرسنال الذي تشتد الحاجة إليه وهو أمر حاسم للاستيلاء
على الأراضي الروسية في أوكرانيا سام
عبد العزيز سي إن إن لندن